House of the Dragon episode 6 is set 10
years after the previous episode so
rhaenyra and Alison Lana and Lenor are
now played by different actors rhaenyra
now has three children joserus called
Jace lucerus called Luke and now baby
Joffrey the father of these children is
officially her husband Lena or valerion
but really the father is Harwin strong
Alison has three children with her
husband King viserys called aegon Helena
and amond and Daemon Targaryen has now
married Lena valerion and they have two
daughters twins called Baylor and Rayna
all of these new kids represented
symbolically in the opening sequence
family tree
so in this episode rhaenyra and
Allison's conflict is passed down to
their children tensions rise and there
are three deaths by fire so what happens
and what does it mean this video has no
spoilers for hot day beyond episode 6.
we see rainyro giving birth and she
looks a lot like her mother Emma Emma
Once told rhaenyra that she would give
birth one day and rhaenyra never wanted
to get married and squeeze out heirs but
she had to marry Leno for a political
Alliance and as heir to the throne she
needs Heirs of her own so her baby
Joffrey is born and a midwife says he's
so healthy he's kicking like a goat
which is a bit ominous because later we
see a goat get killed by a dragon Queen
Alison wants to see Rainier as baby
right away so despite rhaenyra's pain
and discomfort she makes a humiliating
walk through Court while her husband
Lena says some unhelpful things like did
it hurt and I'm glad I'm not a woman and
Lenor sees Kristen Cole last episode 10
years ago Kristen killed lenor's
boyfriend Joffrey lawnmuth at lanor's
wedding Alison has apparently protected
Kristen from punishment so Lenor has
just had to put up with seeing his
boyfriend's murderer every day Lenor
names rhaenyra's baby Joffrey in honor
of Joffrey elonmouth
King viserys looks very old and weak he
is now missing an arm because his arm
was affected by some leprosy-like
disease but viserys is happy to meet his
new grandson viserys says Joffrey has
Leno's nose which is funny because
Joffrey and Jace and Luke looked nothing
like Lenor rhaenyra's Sons don't have
lenor's silver hair or his darker skin
they have dark hair and pale skin like
their real father Harwin strong this is
why Alison wanted to see Rainier's baby
to check if it looks like Lenor or
Harwin Alison tells Lenor do keep trying
you may get one who looks like you it's
a big deal that rhaenyra's sons are
harwans because that means that these
kids are illegitimate bastards and
legally bastards don't inherit like
trueborn children do so arguably
Alison's children should be in line to
the throne not rhaenyra's kids rhaenyra
and harwin's Royal adult story could
destabilize the kingdom it's like in
Game of Thrones when Cersei has bastards
with Jaime instead of having true born
kids with her husband King Robert this
secret could cause War rhaenyra leaves a
trail of blood behind her from her
childbirth like the blood in the opening
sequence this evokes both life and death
the generations of birth and violence
that royal bloodlines are made of
rhaenyra shows Joffrey to his real
father Harwin strong Harwin is now the
commander of the city watch gold cloaks
and it seems like he and rhaenyra and
Lenor are all pretty comfortable with
this secret affair Harwin is a father
figure to the kids Lenor is supportive
rhaenyra and Harwin are affectionate it
would all be pretty wholesome if this
secret wasn't so dangerous rhaenyra says
insolence runs in the family rhaenyra
has always enjoyed breaking rules so
this secrecy and Rebellion seems to be
fun for her their sons Jace and Luke
choose a dragon egg to go in Joffrey's
cradle as is tradition so that Joffrey
will bond with the dragon if it hatches
then Jace and Luke go to the dragon pit
for their dragon lessons alongside
Alison's sons aegon and amond Jace
learns to control his Dragon Vermax
using commands in the Valyrian language
he says dohiris meaning serve which we
have heard before in the phrase Valar
dohiris then he says drakaris
dragonflame to command ver Max to kill a
goat so on one level this scene is fun
and light-hearted as the boys bond with
magical creatures like its Hogwarts but
on another level this scene is really
dark cause dragons are deadly weapons of
war that have killed thousands of people
in recent history and now these children
are taught to use these dangerous beasts
previously this Sarah said that the idea
that we control the dragons is an
illusion today the dragons kill goats
but soon they could bring Doom to humans
so Jace has the dragon Vermax Luke has a
dragon called arax aegon has Sunfire and
Helena has dream fire rhaenyra and Lenor
and most everyone else have their own
dragons but amond doesn't have a dragon
maybe the dragon egg in his cradle
didn't hatch so the boys make fun of
aemond they give him a pig and call it
the pink dread like how balerion was
called the black dread amond is hurt and
angry so amond sneaks down into the pit
maybe hoping to claim a dragon for
himself he faces a dragon which might be
Helena's Dragon dream fire because it's
one of the bigger older dragons but
aemond gets scared and runs off
apparently he's done this before Alison
says aemond is obsessed with dragons
dragons are an important symbol of power
and identity for a Targaryen so will
aemond ever get a dragon and what kind
of person will he become Alison sees her
daughter Helena and Helena is a weirdo
who loves bugs the official guide says
Helena is deeply fascinated with insects
and has a vested interest in their
relationship to humans and the
environment it says that Helena rarely
rides her Dragon dream fire and that she
often speaks in cryptic language Helena
says that a millipede is blind and
blindness is a theme this episode like
alviserys is willfully blind to
rhaenyra's affair with Harwin Helena
also says something about amond that
foreshadows what will happen next
episode so maybe Helena has dreams of
the future like viserys does her dragon
is named dream fire this weird bug girl
could be a source of magic prophecy
elephant seems confused and annoyed with
her Dragon obsessed son and her
bug-obsessed daughter Alison's actor
said that Alison's children are all
[ __ ] weird she goes to viserys and
blames Jace and Luke for the pig
incident even though she knows that
aegon was also to blame sheep turns a
blind eye to that Allison wants to
protect her children and wants to
undermine rhaenyra's bastards Alison
tries to make viserys admit that
rhaenyra's sons are obviously Harwin
Strong's kids not Lanos because of their
dark hair and pale skin but viseris says
genetics can be weird sometimes blonde
people have dark-haired kids which is a
fair point Leno's Grandma Jocelyn was a
Baratheon with black hair and as we
learned in Game of Thrones the seed is
strong children of baratheons almost
always have black hair in the books
Jocelyn's daughter rhaenys has black
hair so maybe rainy says grandkids Jace
Luke and Joff could have black hair even
though Leno has silver hair who knows
but Alison keeps pushing so viserys
Reveals His Real reasoning viserys won't
admit that rhaenyra's kids are bastards
because that would cause conflict people
would question rhaenyra and Jace's claim
to the throne and would want aegon as
Heir instead so his family could be torn
apart by War so instead of addressing
this problem viserys chooses to not see
the truth hoping that if he continues to
do nothing everything will eventually be
fine despite growing evidence that
nothing is fine and the conflicts
getting worse Allison is frustrated she
feels like she's being gaslit when
everyone pretends that rhaenyra's kids
aren't bastards when they clearly are
and she's angry that rhaenyra flaunts
her privilege without shame because this
is not just a political issue for Alison
she has a personal grudge against
rhaenyra Alison resents rhaenyra for
breaking the rules and doing what she
wants while Alison has always followed
the rules and done her duty while
rhaenyra has hot forbidden sex with the
handsome sir Harwin Alison is loyal to
her decrepit and leperous husband
viserys Alison is envious and Furious at
this Injustice and Alison still feels
betrayed that rhaenyra lied to her and
got her father Otto removed as hand of
the King as a proper religious woman
Allison sees Rainier's adultery as
Grievous sin and that as bastards her
children are unfit to rule many
westerosi believe that bastards are
treacherous by Nature there's evil in
their blood Allison believes that by
opposing rhaenyra she's standing up for
truth honor and decency like when Ned
Stark stands up against Cersei and her
lies about her bastards Alison sees
herself as the hero Kristen also hates
rhaenyra he calls her a spider who sucks
her prey dry Kristen feels that rhaenyra
used him for sex breaking his King's
Guard Chastity Earth and feels rejected
that she didn't run away with him
Kristen's whole identity and honor as a
kingsguard was tarnished he almost
committed suicide and he blames rhaenyra
for all of that so Allison and Kristen
have bonded over their shared hatred for
rhaenyra and are determined to bring
down their former friend
Alison visits her other weird child she
finds aegon masturbating out a window
and apparently this is normal behavior
for him because Alison doesn't even
react instead she brings up the pig
incident and she's angry that aegon
bullied amond in public she says it's
fine for aegon to bully amond at home
which is great parenting but she says
that in public aegon and amond must
stand together because rhaenyra and her
sons are a threat rhaenyra may want to
kill aegon to secure her throne which is
the same thing Otto told Alison last
episode aegon doesn't really want the
throne but Alison says he will be king
whether he likes it or not so Alison
drags her son into her conflict it's
similar to when Cersei tells Joffrey
that the Starks are their enemies so
Alison has similarities with both the
villainous Cersei and with the honorable
Ned Stark this is a morally complicated
conflict
Kristen Cole teaches the boys to fight
aegon would rather be perving on girls
but again the adults pushed the children
towards violence aegon and amond were
green like their mother's green dress
while Jace and Luke wear Targaryen black
and red viserys hopes that training
together will make the boys friends but
Kristen pits rhaenyra's kids and
Alison's kids against each other Kristen
wants to prove the truth about Jace and
Luke's parentage so when Harwin drops by
Kristen provokes Harwin by implying that
Harwin is their father until Harwin
snaps and attacks Kristen it's like when
Kristen attacked Joffrey lawnmuth when
his secret was threatened Kristen sees
this reaction as public proof that
rhaenyra's sons are harwin's bastards
it's getting harder to hide the
dangerous truth rhaenyra uses a secret
passage in the red keep to listen to
Harwin arguing with his father Lionel
Lionel says harwin's treasonous adultery
with rhaenyra could get him and his
children killed or exiled so while
rhaenyra is stressed over the danger to
her family and her body is still
recovering from childbirth her husband
Lenor bursts in drunk and says unhelpful
things about her breasts Lenor is
excited that there's new fighting in the
stepstones Lenor had fun last time he
went to war there now he wants to go
back for Fun and Profit rhaenyra
criticizes Lenor for partying while
their family is in danger she says it is
their agreement that Lenor can do what
he wants while rhaenyra does what and
who she wants but now that people are
questioning her son's parentage she
commands Lenor to stay by her side Lenor
tries to say that this marriage has been
hard for him too but rhaenyra shuts him
down so rhaenyra and Leno's relationship
is not going great but they stick
together as the storm gathers a around
them we see a small council meeting
rhaenyra and Alison are present as the
heir and the queen all while seems to be
the new Grand maester to replace Melos
so maybe Melos has died previously
Orwell suggested some different
treatments for viserys's sickness so now
that all while has taken over maybe his
treatments are the reason why viserys is
still alive 10 years later the books do
suggest that viserys gets better because
of all Wild's treatments what we don't
know is whether Melos was deliberately
making viscera sick as part of a
conspiracy with Otto or if Melos was
just a crappy doctor now that Lionel
strong is hand there's a new master of
laws called Jasper Wilde Jasper is
nicknamed iron Rod because he's so
strict and hard though in the books
mushroom claims that he's called iron
Rod because of the stiffness of his
penis iron Rod had 29 children on 4y
lives until the last one died of
exhaustion Thailand Lannister is still
master of ships and Lyman beesbury is
still master of coin though he's getting
old and Confused the council discuss a
land dispute between house Blackwood and
house Bracken these families have been
fighting each other for thousands of
years we saw a Blackwood kill a Bracken
previously the blackwoods and brackens
are both ruled by their overlord's house
Tully they mentioned that Lord Grover
Tully is old so his son rules for him in
the books Grover's grandson is called
Elmo Tully and Elmo has kids called
Kermit and Oscar Author George Martin
named these characters after Muppets
Allison and rhaenyra have different
opinions on how to deal with these
Muppets and they contradict each other
passive aggressively rhaenyra knows
she's in danger from this conflict with
Allison so she tries to make peace she
apologizes for any offense and reminds
Alison of when they were friends and she
proposes for Alison's daughter Helena to
marry her son and Heir jaserys so that
Jace and Helena can rule Westeros
together after Rainier she also offers
dragon eggs so maybe amond can finally
get a dragon rhaenyra's Grand proposal
is undermined when milk leaks from her
breasts at the worst possible moment
rhaenyra's actor says rhaenyra is at
odds with her gender and is frustrated
with the limitations and indignities of
Womanhood viserys is excited at this
opportunity for peace and unity in his
family but Alison refuses The Proposal
says not till she's cold in her grave
Alison doesn't want to marry her only
daughter to rhaenyra's bastard she wants
to reveal the truth the rhaenyra's kids
are illegitimate and that her own kids
are the rightful heirs so Alison sticks
to the truth and the rules but she also
prolongs a dangerous conflict partly
because of her own personal grudge
against rhaenyra Alison looks after
viserys with their age Gap viserys looks
more like Alison's Grandpa than her
husband sick and weak viserys
increasingly follows Allison's lead
Lionel strong tries to resign as hand of
the king Lionel knows his family is in
danger because of harwin's affair with
rhaenyra so he wants to get as far away
from Court as possible for safety Alison
tries to get Lionel to admit that the
affair is true but Lionel refuses to say
why he's resigning so viserys refuses to
accept his resignation and just allows
Lionel to take Harwin to harrenhal
Allison is left infuriated with these
farcical lies and [ __ ] Alison has
dinner with Laris strong the son of
Lionel and brother of Harwin larus is
apparently now a spy master for Allison
telling her about happenings in the cape
we still don't know how larus gets his
information whether it's spies or secret
passages or magically controlling rats
as a green Seer but we see Ellison's
maid Talia a few times this episode
Antalya even has an entry on the
official Guide website so maybe Italia
is Laris and Allison's spy Alison says
she wishes her father Otto who was still
hand of the king because he would
support her in this conflict with
rhaenyra But Otto can't be the hand
while Lionel strong is the hand so larys
decides to murder his own father larus
visits the dungeons in the books Laris
works as the Confessor or torturer here
he gets some prisoners and cuts out
their tongues so that he can use them to
commit crimes and they can't blab or
reveal that Laris was behind it it's
like how Varys removes the tongues of
his child's spy eyes in the books as
these screaming men are mutilated larus
Smiles mildly most of the characters in
this show are morally gray but it's
increasingly clear that Laris is
straight up evil a murderer and
manipulator without remorse
Harwin strong leaves for harrenhal and
farewells his secret lover and his
children Jace asks rhaenyra if Harwin is
his real father and rhaenyra doesn't
tell him she just says that he's a
Targaryen because he's her son it can
really mess a kid up to not know their
family and identity especially in this
world where parentage and bloodline are
everything Jace is old enough to know
that bastards are widely hated in
Westeros so how will he and his brothers
handle their identity how will they feel
about Harwin and lanor is blood
everything or does adoptive family
matter too maybe Lenor can be a real
father to the boys like how Ned Stark
was a father to Jon Snow
with Harwin gone rhaenyra decides to
leave King's Landing she tried making
peace with Alison and Alison refused the
rumors of her Affair are getting too
dangerous so she goes to Dragonstone The
ancestral Targaryen Island near King's
Landing rhaenyra tells Leno to bring his
boyfriend Carl because they will need
every sword it sounds like rhaenyra is
giving up on peace and now expects to
fight for the throne when viserys dies
Lionel and Harwin returned to their
castle harrenhal and they're shadowed by
Larissa's men these men wear a firefly
symbol because Laris has a firefly on
his walking cane it doesn't actually
make any sense to put your logo on your
super secret mute crime agents but this
shows the viewer that these are
Larissa's men larisas fireflies start a
fire in aronhal that kills Lionel and
kills all one in the books it's a
mystery who burned harrenhal some say
Corliss did it to kill Harwin because
Harwin cockolded lanor some say Daemon
burned Harwin because Harwin was a rival
for rhaenyra's love some say viserys
burned Harwin to stop the rumors of
Harwin and rhaenyra's Affair but in Hot
D Laris bones harrenhal he kills his own
father and brother in a world where
kinslaying is the most terrible crime
larus does this because with his family
dead Laris will become the new Lord of
harrenhal and now that Lionel is dead
Otto can become hand of the King again
like Alison wanted Alison is horrified
when she finds out she didn't want Laris
to murder anyone but Lara says that he
did it for her as though Alison is
complicit in the crime these murders tie
Allison to Laris he has dirt on her now
he says that she owes him Alaris gives a
villainous speech saying that loving
your family makes you weak and it's true
that viserys rhaenyra and Alison all put
themselves in danger for the sake of
their children children can give you
Legacy but they're also a liability
Laris chooses to live without love so
there's nothing he won't do
Laris says that people will blame his
fire on the harrenhal curse because
every family to hold harrenhal has come
to a terrible end harrenhal was first
built by an ironborn warlord called
Haron the black he enslaved thousands of
riverlanders building his monstrous
Castle working people to death that said
to be blood in the mortar but just after
Haron completed harrenhal aegon the
Conqueror came and burned the castle
killing Aaron and his family so then
house kaherus ruled harrenhal but the
kahirises were soon slaughtered by
Outlaws then house haraway took over
harrenhal until they were wiped out by
maegor the cruel then house Towers to
Karen Hall but then they went extinct so
now that how strong has harrenhal no one
is surprised that half the family
mysteriously died in this cursed haunted
place meanwhile across the narrow Daemon
Targaryen is now married to Lena
valerion we saw them flirting last
episode 10 years ago in the books Leno
was betrothed to the son of the Sea Lord
of braavos at the time so Daemon killed
the bravosi in a jewel so that he could
marry Lana Daemon and Lena then went
traveling in the East they went to
pentos volantis kohor novos and mushroom
claims that they visited the ruins of
valyria then Daemon and Lena had twins
called Baylor and Rayna Baylor is named
after daemon's father Balon and Rayna is
named after Lena's mother rhaenys now
Lena is pregnant again and they're
hosted in pentos by Reggio hiratas
Reggio is the prince of pantos which in
the books is a mostly ceremonial
position the prince attends feasts and
balls and ritually D flowers two maidens
each new year and then is occasionally
killed killed as a sacrifice to appease
the gods the real power in pentos is
held by the magisters rich Traders like
illyrio mapatus who hosts Daenerys and
viserys in Game of Thrones slavery is
officially banned in pentos but they
keep slaves anyway and call it debt
bondage so these servants we see with
Reggio might actually be slaves Reggio
wants Daemon and Lena's help because
he's worried about the triaki the
triarchy is the alliance of tyrosh mere
and Lease who have been attacking the
stepstones previously Daemon killed the
leader of the triarchy kragas crab
feeder but the triaki is becoming a
problem again they're now led by a
flamboyant tairoshi called recalio
rindoon and the triarchies made an
alliance with Prince Corin Martell of
Dawn at this time Dawn isn't part of
Westeros it's still its own kingdom and
vendors occasionally Ward with Targaryen
Kings Reggio is worried that the triaki
could soon be a threat to pentos so he
wants daemon's family and their dragons
to stay and defend pentos Daemon has the
dragon karaxis Lena now has the dragon
Vega and their daughter Baylor has a
young dragon called Moon Dancer we see
Daemon and Lena perform an air show with
karaxis and Vega and we see how massive
Vega is vegar is the biggest and oldest
known creature in the world at about 170
years old vegar's first writer was Queen
visenya Targaryen The sister wife of
aegon the Conqueror alongside balerion
the black dread and maraxis Vega burned
thousands of people in aegon's Conquest
later Veigar was written by Balon
Targaryen the father of viserys and
Daemon and now Lena valarion has claimed
vegar weebs Soul laner asking about Vega
years ago when she was a kid vegar is
now ancient and sleepy like a big old
dinosaur Grandma but she's still
terrifying when roused the hardened
Survivor of a hundred battles so Vega
and karaxis would be a huge help in
defending pentos so Reggio offers them
land and luxuries in pentos if they'll
stay lainer doesn't want to stay in
pentos she wants to raise her children
at home on driftmark and to embrace
their identity as Valyrian Dragon Riders
but Daemon wants to stay daemon's trying
to run away from his feelings away from
his painful relationships with his
brother viserys and nice rhaenyra away
from the politics and plots and away
from the constant drama that he
constantly creates Daemon tries to be
content in pentos but it's clearly not
working Lena says Daemon doesn't sleep
he doesn't go out in pentos he obviously
misses his family he's always reading
books about valyria Daemon can't escape
his desires and Ambitions as a Targaryen
Daemon and Elena's daughter Rayna feels
rejected and left out because she
doesn't have a dragon her dragon egg
hasn't hatched she says Daemon spends
more time with Baylor teaching her
Valyrian while Rayna feels ignored Elena
assures Rayner that she could still get
a dragon like how Lena got a dragon
later in life rayna's situation not
having a dragon is similar to amon's
Lana goes into labor but the childbirth
goes badly like with Queen Emma the
doctor says the mother is gonna die they
can either let the baby die with her or
cut the mother open to try to save the
baby either way Lena is doomed but
unlike Emma Lena chooses how she dies
she doesn't want to die in bed she says
she wants a dragon Rider's death so
Elena goes out to wear dragonvega and
tells vegar to burn her and at first
vegar refuses this shows that dragons
are intelligent and have feelings and
will of their own Vega doesn't want to
kill her master but maybe vegar sees
that Lena is in pain and is dying so
then vegar obeys and kills Lana and her
unborn baby like Emma Lena dies
violently but at least Lena got to
choose now maybe Daemon knows how
viserys felt when his wife Emma died
Daemon is now a single dad to Baylor and
Rayna will he keep trying to run away
from his identity and from politics or
will he fulfill Lena's wish and raise
his kids at their family home Baylor and
Reina have never been to driftmark or
King's Landing Daemon is the only family
they know so what will be their place in
the world in the books the year of Elena
Lionel and harwin's deaths is called the
year of the red spring this is the year
when everything started to go horribly
wrong and the year is not over yet
if you want to know the full story of
Hot D and about the history and
Mysteries of Westeros you gotta check
out the books there's the main series
and Fire and Blood and Duncan egg and
the world book and you can get any one
of these on audiobook for free right now
at audible.com ASX sign up for a Premium
Plus trial membership and you get an
audiobook to keep even if you cancel the
trial you can get Game of Thrones or
Lord of the Rings or Dune membership
also includes unlimited access to
thousands of audiobooks and shows in the
audible plus catalog sign up at
audible.com ASX or text ASX to 500-500
thanks for watching we're doing a live
stream and an explained video each week
so like comment and subscribe and check
out the podcast feeds linked below thank
you to the patrons maxpal Aja Martinez
Mark Van Der Sam Heather Upton Zach
Robles and Greg tingus cheers